the book
make changes out i think um
you're a national treasure man and i
appreciate i appreciate everything you
do and i also appreciate the way you
navigate a lot of the negativity that
comes your way
yeah thank you man um i think there's a
lot that can be learned
from the way you handle a lot hey when
did you see the andrew schultz thing he
did about you
oh yeah man i mean you know i hated that
because
you know like guys like andrew like i
like andrew
and it's like why why do that like i've
never had a
and andrew and i have several mutual
friends and it's just like
it it's sometimes it's an outer body
experience man it's
almost like being featured on snl
low-key but i do feel like there was
just so
you know there's a thin line between it
being comedy and it being like yo you're
for
like he forms a lot of people's opinions
with those bits he's been doing yeah
and um it is what it is man you know i i
see part of it as
because i'm so public at this point it's
gonna it's gonna mean that i'm subject
to misinformation
to comedy to to whatever so i don't take
it personally
i just but i do hate it because it's
like damn dude you could have literally
reached out to me
yeah and gotten better information but
his job
is his job is to kind of be a comedic
[ __ ] like i mean that
not even as an insult that's kind of
history
and uh his stick is to to push the
envelope
and to kind of be a hilarious [ __ ]
and he's great at what he does
it just sucks when you're on the
receiving end of it but i don't i can't
generally speaking i can't dwell on it
for long
i see it think about it and i gotta keep
it moving